a wnba team has won the championship
what is the wnba team i don't really
know there was a championship apparently
i did you watch it no you didn't not a
single person listening to this show
right now watched the wnba championship
or probably even knew that it was going
on
i don't think anyone did in the country
maybe some of the basketball players
themselves knew but i'm not even
convinced of that so one of the teams
won because i guess one of the teams has
to win and they hold a championship
parade
in chicago
the the championship parade i forget if
i print it out no unfortunately i didn't
there was a headline it said chicago
turns out
for the wnba championship parade and
there's
big buses here and double deckers and
people standing on top waving to the
adoring fans except
there was nobody there in the streets to
greet them
so you can see there's multiple buses
whole stream
you can hear the sirens behind them
and
now you just hear
it's so sad
it's so sad you hear so the streets are
are empty i mean there are a couple
people like bicycling alongside them
there are a bunch of cops
trailing them giving them a bit of a
motorcade but there's
almost not a single person out in the
street for the parade because no one
cares because it's the wnba and no one
even knew it was on
th this is sad this is sadder than not
having a parade
okay i'm not i don't begrudge the ladies
their
victory i don't i'm not interested in it
i don't
you know there are a lot of sports i
don't watch the curling championships
okay i don't watch
the you know international shuffleboard
world series right i don't either just i
don't pay attention to a lot of these
things and certainly not to the wnba
but
what's so sad here
is broader than just the wnba it's the
problem with
pride culture it's the problem with the
i'm awesome kind of culture
i saw
oh this was so sad i saw someone that i
went to school with i was just scrolling
through instagram and i saw she posted
this picture
and and underneath she wrote i'm so
proud of this person i love this person
so much this person's doing such a great
job and i'm really proud of her
and it was a photo of herself
it was a f and i thought this is really
sad
but it's a common occurrence these days
you it's the self-love
self-care
kind of culture where you you basically
just worship the self and the fact is if
you have to say it you probably don't
think it
right this is
i mean now we have whole months for
pride and for celebrating oneself
but
this is
quite the opposite of the traditional
understanding in our christian
civilization which is rather than saying
i'm awesome i'm the best i'm perfect
just the way i am we say i'm a miserable
sinner please have mercy on me i'm
broken i'm i've failed
i i have sinned in my thoughts and in my
words and what i have done and what i've
failed to do through my fault through my
fault through my most grievous fault
that that's the traditional
understanding and
ironically or perhaps unexpectedly
that view of yourself will make you feel
much better about yourself and about the
world one because it's true we are all
broken the imagination of man's heart is
evil from the beginning the things we
want to do we don't do and the things we
don't want to do we do we are sinful and
we are in need of salvation
but
two there is salvation we actually can
find it but we're not going to find it
in ourselves all right we're not going
to perfect ourselves of purely of our
own work it's just not going to happen
the the
pride culture i think ultimately is is
just masking
a deep sorrow and a deep sort of despair
because if you are going to rely on
yourself to perfect your own life or to
perfect the world you are going to be
extremely
disappointed
would have been much better and and much
more attractive if these women had said
you know okay we played this game but no
one cares that's fine but maybe you keep
watching we did it for ourselves we did
it for the excellence of the sport
humility is much more attractive than
pride this is something we used to know
now we somehow have forgotten that pride
goes before destruction and a haughty
spirit before a fall i'm so glad you
liked that clip but stop hold up
ring that bell
yeah please you have to okay they don't
want you youtube does not want you to
get the notifications all the time okay
ring the bell subscribe head on over to
the michael knowles show at apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your podcasts
type it in
m-i-c-h-a-l-k-w-l-e-s
o w
fury
subscribe we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]